hi everyone its Johanna here so inner
thigh gap and slim waist has always been
the most requested workouts and that is
why we're going to do today but before
we start it's important to know that we
are all made in different shapes and
sizes and that we are all beautiful
not everybody can have inner thigh gap
because it really comes down to your
bone structure how wide your hip bones
are set apart but that does not mean we
cannot turn up and slim down on our
inner thighs
so today's workout is about defining and
toning out our inner thighs as well as
to turn up on our abs to give us a nice
slim waist don't forget to eat clean as
well so let's get started don't forget
to do your warm-ups at least 5 minutes
long I'm going to do a quick warm-up by
doing some squats this entire workout
will last you six minutes long per set
and I will need to do three sets each
workout will be one minute long 45
seconds of workouts and 15 seconds of
rest all the workouts will be working on
your inner thighs as well as your weight
so it's going to be intense but it's
going to give you the results you want
okay so really pump up your energy just
push yourself through the six minutes
rest and push yourself through another
two more sets
all right good so I'm going to set a
timer and we're going to start so the
first one gal is sumo squat and twist so
stand in the web position squat down and
twist up to work on your waist and I
want you to bring your arms up make sure
they elbow touches your knees and twist
okay
always keep your arms up to guide you to
go as low as you can your elbows must
touch your knees
it's not touching you're not going alone
enough good so you should be feeling
your inner thighs as well as your waist
as you're twisting you can use a
dumbbell if you want to this is 2 kilos
or you can just do it without example
good rest
same thing 45 seconds on the other side
all right so take a breather make sure
that you're setting wider path to the
space emails ready let's go almost
touching and twist and feel your inner
thighs working as a squatting down
you're not going to keep your body in a
straight position get how much keep
going really squat see your inner thighs
your father's wall and your waist keep
going good jump almost there keep going
doing well keep your arms up don't drop
your arms elbows touching your knees and
rest drop the weights second workout
sumo squat stupid arms up with leg raise
ok so this will be working on your inner
thighs and your uncle Isis long so and
squeeze it good make sure they are
squeezing all the way up I was touching
your knees squeeze good job right no
cheating no half way all the way up and
squeeze doing the thighs on the way up
good job there you go nice
so you having your arms up in a boxer
position get keep your body straight
look ahead you feel that crying nice one
squeeze it keep going alright last one
and rest
same thing onto your right side okay
drink it very good
get ready take a breather
right let's go down squeeze good job now
gently nice this is a really simple
moves but it would really target the
inner thighs and your waist as you're
squeezing up good job
so instead of breaking only on one part
of your body we want to be focusing on
multiple parts for your benefits as well
as to save time keep going nice view you
know final almost touching your knees
squeeze last one and rest third workout
jumping side to side so it's literally
like slight lunges but I wanted to jump
site to site and spread as wide as you
can to feel your inner thighs
ready go jump should be one at all and
through your inner thighs and your
thighs working at the same time okay it
keeps your pendants up keep going really
go as wide as you can
good jump keep pushing
nice one come on keep your body low if
you need to really spread wide as you
can
you're sure there's nothing around you
good jump and rest thought work out we
were going on the floor in a plank
position
okay what we want to do it's melting the
fiber glass John plank so up multiply
both bowties and jump out in okay so one
two three four out in good job one three
four out in find your rhythm to it try
to keep your body in a straight line
throughout good so you're really working
on analyze your legs and your core who
loves Martin cover let's go out in you
can breathe you don't lose one sit out
in good are you doing nothing and rest
that was one set okay rest for 30
seconds 40 seconds and we're going to
repeat the entire thing again just
ignore that take them take some pretty
good need to do some water if you need
to and we'll be starting soon are you
ready now that you know the workout
let's give it your all and really push
all the way through so let's start with
sumo squat and Chris let's go stand what
comes up panties good job keep going
really target your inner thighs
and your ways like I say if you find
this difficult to begin with you can
drop the weight and slow down the
workout it's more important that you get
the techniques right and do the right
parts of your body then to rush the
workouts keep going almost touch your
knees twist good job twist over there
and now rest good change side let's get
going if you feel your heart rate going
up and you should be sweating and that
is good Oh up and go reach good job
really twist and reach as far as you can
all right up keep going OOP breathe in
and out find a rhythm to your breathing
it will help with your workouts good
that's it keep squatting
[Music]
doing it booth there whoo let's go
last one
Andres drop the weights and now squat
with leg raises okay let's start with
our left side ready I was up let's go
down squeeze your bum good squeeze up
squeeze your bum in the thighs good job
just like a fighter
let's go you've got to work hard for the
body you want if you're not sweating
you're not gaining okay all these tips
work and dedication but it's going to be
so worth it all right keep going almost
there
squeeze one more and rest good job take
a breather
it just echoes if you need to on the
other side now on top legs wide apart
and that's the cube go up good jump shot
intense workouts a better than none so
don't have the time to do long workouts
choose short and intense because they're
equally burning as much calories good so
really squeeze spread your legs
three mil I was there keep going
not now do not stop now you've got two
more workouts to go to complete your
second set keep pushing
one more rest good job don't wake up
Jonah site-to-site okay so the guy as
long as you can and try to spread spread
your legs as wide as you can
ready let's go John good really very
nice and your legs working and your core
is the one that's helping you to stay
upright and to keep your balance keep
going okay you're doing well
come on push it push it
do not stop when you're tired stop only
when you're done good rest forth or go
down on this wall mountain climber with
John flag okay
can you see me good up Watson climb up
go four times jump out in out in one
rhythm good try to keep your body as
straight as possible out it come on keep
going really push your thighs and
tighten your core over there one more
breast very very very good job now that
was two sets done and now I want you to
put yourself and do another set that's
the cue for you to start each set is
only six minutes long and the total
workout takes you less than twenty
minutes long so there's no reason why
you don't have the time or you can't do
it if you want to slim inner thighs as
well as same waist don't forget to check
out my meal plans to go along with this
workout do it three times weekly on
every other day all the best for new
fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do you
follow me on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter to stay connected with me
thanks guys
[Music]